pentek otto and his team have been
preparing for a good three weeks they've
been putting the finishing touches on
the exclusive dinner hosted by the
German president at the German press
bowl this beetroot salad isn't a mousse
girl from the chef I think it needs to
be spiced up a bit but it's wonderful
fresh elegant the concentration in the
kitchen is intense all the courses are
prepared simultaneously to the desert
stewed apricots with white chocolate
pineapple tarragon cream and milk
skinned it's really great the Africa the
estragon the herbs the white chocolate
milk it's perfect awesome very nice 15
taste testers are on hand to try the
sample meal at least 300 prominent
palates will have to be pleased at the
ball so in spite of his two Michelin
stars and legato isn't taking any risks
I'd rather play it safe and stick to
classic dishes so more guests will be
happy this is just the opposite of what
we do in the restaurant typical of
Otto's cooking style are some basics
from home cooking he garnishes the
eggplant lasagna with path to buckwheat
auto consulted a colleague to find out
the German president's tastes he told me
the president likes fish with fried
potatoes a lot this of course is a
challenge but we integrated it into our
dinner this is my interpretation of
fried potatoes the needle walketh off a
nice Park touch mine and we had actually
planned for cod wanted that to happen
behind indoor ski plan I'll differ but
to organize the requested meat so we
decided to do braised beef instead ish
mortis took from event handler grew up
on a farm in eastern Germany he learned
how to cook from some of the country's
top chefs
he earned his first michelin star at the
age of 28 he's been cooking at the
logins addon estimate since 2010 the
restaurant itself also has two Michelin
stars and it's shortlisted for a third
that would make it Berlin's first
three-star restaurant Mitch la will be
announcing its verdict on December the
first I let's live in a million everyone
in Berlin is in suspense every chef with
two stars or even one or none is
motivated to work for the accolade and
they're all on edge anyone who isn't
nervous must be in the wrong profession
but we'll forget Henrik likes to compare
cooking with driving Formula One races
he's always pushing the limits he's
cooked for many VIPs but the tension
never subsides wrong bus Pasiphae mother
you thought of everything and then
something happens so I'm always on edge
that's part of it every evening when the
restaurant opens you think what'll
happen today what kind of patrons are
coming forgive the taste testers have
arrived among them leading partners and
sponsors of the German press ball even
the sample meal is a tradition it allows
the organisers to fine-tune the last
details Scott Dunn shemagh installing
some fantastic ideas from past years and
then at the rehearsal dinner we can't
even see each other so we have to make
slight changes to the decorations or the
colors of the flowers have to be a shade
different you might say we'll be dotting
the i's this evening what arm does
eating food shouldn't off before below
the cooks are putting the finishing
touches on the first course the cream of
celery soup Hendrick Otto is satisfied
with the result
the clinica of course we can't make
everybody happy but we try and we hope
we've done a good job of it last year I
was really pleased and we got very good
feedback I hope very much that will pull
it off again this year the rehearsal
dinner is over now it has to pass muster
with the VIPs at the German press ball
you